[Music]
i use not only design but biology
to create new materials which actually
are fully sustainable and biodegradable
my first material that i focused on
developing
was sweat crystallization this was a
method that i worked alongside with
imperial college of
collecting people's sweat and extracting
out basically the sodiums the lactic
acids
and the estrogen to make these
bio crystals which are then embellished
onto these fashioned
materials i also developed bio-based
plastics unlike most bio
plastics which are available in market
is made a hundred percent
from natural ingredients so mine is a
base
of different things like seaweed flowers
and natural earth
i first went into making biodegradable
face shields because
one of the issues that i'd always had
with my bio-based plastics was
they didn't have the longevity of
plastics because
of provide there was a mass increase of
single-use plastics being discarded
so for me it seemed like a great
opportunity to have a material which
didn't have a longevity of plastic that
could degrade
back into the earth the more
that we start understanding about
natural materialization and
understanding about the earth
it's really the best way that we're
actually going to start becoming
more sustainable